the former doctor for the USA gymnastics
team pleaded guilty to sexually
molesting seven girls
Larry Nasser said in court yesterday he
hopes that his victims can start the
healing process three-time Olympic gold
medalist Ali Reis man who was not part
of this case tweeted yesterday Larry is
a monster not a doctor Jericka Duncan
spoke with some of the victims after the
hearing he was charismatic he was
gregarious he was charming he was
everything a pedophile typically is
Rachel dan Hollander was referred to in
court papers as victims see on Wednesday
she watched as Larry Nasser admitted to
sexually assaulting her and six others
[Music]
who were all 15 or younger at the time I
pray the rosary every day for
forgiveness for their what did you make
of his apology I think it said Larry
psychological state and he will take
every opportunity to shift the attention
back onto himself so try to make himself
look less evil than he really is the
judge admonished Nasir the former team
doctor for USA Gymnastics and Michigan
State University for molesting young
athletes he was supposed to be treating
for injuries you violated the oath that
you took which is to do no harm and you
harm to them selfishly more than 130
women have now accused Nasser of abuse
including three-star US gymnast Aly
Raisman mckayla maroney
and Gabby Douglas who came forward only
on Tuesday race men spoke with 60
minutes earlier this month you know when
I see these young girls that come up to
me and they ask for pictures or
autographs whatever it is I just I can't
every time I look at them every time I
see them smiling I just think I just
want to create change so that they never
ever have to go through that Nasser who
also pleaded guilty in a federal child
porn case in July now faces a minimum of
25 years behind bars for each of the
seven counts of criminal sexual conduct
he will be sentenced in January for CBS
this morning
Jericka Duncan Lansing Michigan
according to Larry Nasser's lawyers the
plea deal resolves all of his charged an
uncharged conduct for more than 125
cases under investigation by the
Michigan attorney general's office